Freaking says fans,
our chancellor for the authentic individual.
Well
that's a tough one.
You know,
I mean,
cancer know that.
That's too,
that's too dramatic.
I guess that what you're pointing out is the danger of saying,
and I can certainly appreciate that.
I can't say that I'm particularly comfortable with it,
which might seem to be rather hypocritical as it isn't.
Like I've shied away from exposing my views in public.
Um,
but I felt that I was driven to that by necessity and also by my desire to
educate people.
Um,
however,
I would say despite the fact that I'm somewhat uncomfortable with it,
I think that's mostly because of the responsibility.
You know what,
I've been terrified for a whole year that I'd say something,
you know,
unforgivably stupid and,
demolish myself in public and,
and,
you know,
feel guilty and horrible about that for the rest of my life.
And so far it'd be fortunate there's been some close calls,
but I've been fortunate.
But you know,
now when I go places,
people often recognize me.
Even at this little town we went up to this weekend,
there were two people that came up to me in the parking lot and we're excited to
meet me.
And you know,
the vast majority of encounters,
all of the encounters I have with people in public and have been really
wonderful.
I have to say that the people have been extremely friendly and you know,
sometimes they're a bit star struck,
which I find strange.
I can see the projection,
you know,
so it's,
it's unsettling for me,
although I'm not judging anybody for it.
Um,
it's just a strange thing to observe.
but you know,
I can't complain about the fact that people are,
are,
uh,
are positively predisposed to what I'm doing.
I mean,
it's such a privilege.
I can't imagine what it would be like to be hated publicly.
I think that would just kill me.
I really think that.
But,
um,
so I mean it's,
it's,
I suppose there's the possibility of having that sort of thing go to your head
and it's it,
and I mean that happens to people,
but I think I've said this before,
maybe on the Q and A's.
I have a pretty sensible family and I have a pretty,
um,
what would you say?
Yeah,
I have a pretty good sense of my limitations.
So I would say,
um,
let's,
we could even call it an acute sense and so I'm not particularly worried that
this is going to go to my head in some way that that would
no
inflate my ego or something like that.
Huh.
I mean,
I think one of the things I have noticed is that I might be little less patient
with people when I'm speaking,
um,
because I'm more used to that,
more use to that might be good for me to be listened to and so I have to watch
that.
But I'm pretty,
I've always been pretty noisy and talkative and so that's probably something
that's plagued me or being a characteristic of me ever since I was a little tiny
kid.
I mean,
I used to talk all the time when I was a little,
little,
little guy.
I mean,
I think my cousin Eric Pony,
he probably listens to this.
He used to call the motor mouth and that was the boat.
Exactly right.
I was like a miniature Camille Paglia.
So,
um,
anyways,
I can't complain about having,
let's say,
fans I,
people have been unbelievably good to be,
and I'm really grateful for that.
So,
um.